I'm sitting here with an amazing actor
fitness guru an incredibly guru
incredibly cool dude Joe Manganiello
from True Blood it's great to be here
here HBO
ah so you're very good-looking what's
that all about
I understand you forewent hair and
makeup yeah man I met just a guy from
Pittsburgh through and through you know
any time I can skip the hair and makeup
trailer I'm okay with it yeah but you
look like you went through hair and
makeup that's not fair I think I've been
to Pittsburgh and I went to the Warhol
Museum oh it's not there it's fantastic
it is fantastic amazing it's a great
Museum
I don't normally smoke weed but I did we
would get drunk on absinthe with the
wormwood in it and I don't know it it's
it's really trippy and why it's what's
like um it's like um I don't know it
stays you know like they have like peach
flavored absolute it'd be like shrooms
flavored absolutely you know so you're
kind of tripping oh I have a bottle of
it at home
I've never women to drink it and now my
god totally gonna go all [__] a night
and get I am mad [__] I'm going after
party at peak what the hell yeah it's
cut this thing going I disappointed the
size of my one-bedroom apartment
we drank it well yeah we're drinking
this episode getting real messed up and
then my girlfriend at the time stopped
by and she worked for the ATF she was
with the federal government oh yeah oh
that's grand dad she looked like um
motor I'm like yeah she looked like she
was on Baywatch
so it was like what she heard a gun and
it was just a robbery trip you know hair
Baywatch girlfriend with your magic
drinks looking at real world it's not
fair that you also have a personality
that's for us for us let's talk about
you know marijuana wagon the deck oh
right now I don't mean to load you into
the obvious thing but I have to imagine
doing it gave you an appreciation of
maybe how difficult it is or how fun it
could be I mean it's tiring
yes yeah I mean you have to keep
hydrated hey I mean I try to get to bed
early stay limber never yeah you get
stretch a lot roll out stay mostly Lynne
um yeah I mean when you know there's a
Taoist principle that I try to live by
when the when the bow is not in use do
not keep the string taut applies to deck
swing just relax
when you're not shooting arrows don't
fluff don't flap just let it be did you
give it a little a little I mean you're
going out on set yeah it's got to be a
little chilly
um yeah surprisingly except when I was
painted head-to-toe in gold body paint
they have to you go yeah I'm painted
gold that's it the only way to make you
more attractive it's the paint you go oh
and like a printout of your tax returns
from way yeah I'm reliable
it is texted yeah I'm a tattoo on your
abs that say I'm a great listener could
you just leave some for the rest of us
yeah I just broke up with my girlfriend
shitty boss she said I listened too much
I
you son-of-a-bitch